we'll put a gun in every Taiwanese
household train them how to use it that
is how you make Xi Jinping think twice
do you really think that would be a
sufficient plan to deter a Chinese
Invasion if it includes long-range
missiles ground troops an aerial
blockade a naval blockade
Caitlin Caitlyn of course it's not
sufficient you take that tiny little
clip when I've articulated it the Nixon
Library last week a one-hour speech with
a whole range of deterrence that is part
of it but I've also said that I would
pull Russia out of its military alliance
with China I've also said that we would
bolster our partnership with India to be
able to close the Andaman Sea and the
Malacca straight I've also said that we
would actually send a signal very
clearly that we will defend to Taiwan
moving from strategic ambiguity to
strategic Clarity to say that we will
defend Taiwan until we have
semiconductor Independence in this
country